Salut ! Aujourd'hui c'est la 288 ème vidéo du Mental Vlog et ce n'est pas un hasard si vous êtes en train de regarder cette vidéo !
A la fin de cette vidéo, je donne quelques infos pour ceux qui voudrait me rencontrer, mais pour le moment je vais vous apprendre à prendre la bonne décision en jouant votre vie à pile ou face.
[musique du générique]
Quand on doit prendre une décision, je m'aide souvent d'un tableau avec des "+" et des"-".
Ça m'aide à y voir plus clair et à être le plus pragmatique possible dans ma prise de décision.
Mais parfois même quand on fait ça, on a quand même du mal à déterminer quel est le meilleur choix.
Parce que dans la balance les deux choix se valent en tout cas avec toutes les informations  qu'on a à ce moment là, les deux choix sont à peu près équilibrés.
Et il y a quelques semaines voir quelques mois, en discutant avec une amie, on a parlé de la prise de décision par pile ou face.
Et je vais vous révéler en quoi la réponse de la pièce est tout à fait juste.
Malgré le fait qu'elle soit lancé au hasard !
Il faut déjà comprendre que l'hésitation ça entraîne le doute, qui elle-même entraîne l'inaction.
L'idée est donc qu'une fois qu'on a rationalisé sa prise de décision mais que le choix reste impossible, d’éviter le doute pour casser le processus.
"Casser", n'étant pas un placement de produit !
"-Ah bon ?! Donc j'enlève le commentaire ?" [imite les abonnés]
Oui ! Enlève ce commentaire là.
Au final, la bonne décision sera celle qui nous ressemble et qui marche avec notre conviction intime.
Et pour déterminer quelle est notre conviction intime, une simple pièce peut suffire !
Avant de lancer la pièce, il faut vraiment jouer le jeu mentalement, et se dire:
"-Ok, je vais faire confiance au hasard, et je vais suivre la décision de la pièce.
Donc si elle tombe sur face, je fais le choix 1. Et si elle tombe sur pile, je fais le choix 2."
Vous lancez la pièce, vous regardez le résultat, et donc quel choix est indiqué par la pièce,
et vous devez assumer ce choix comme un choix obligatoire.
Comme s'il n'y avait pas d'autre possibilité, vous suivez le jeu du pile ou face.
Jusque là je pense que l’explication est claire.
Immédiatement après ça, vous analysez de suite votre émotion brute.
Si vous avez une simple amertume, ou envie de relancer la pièce, ou juste un pincement au cœur, ça veut dire que ce choix là ne correspond pas à votre conviction intime.
Et que votre vraie conviction profonde se porte donc sur l'autre choix.
Et si au contraire, vous êtes raccord avec ce que disait la pièce, ça veut dire que c'est votre conviction profonde et là vous pouvez foncer.
Parce que en tant que Mentalo, vous avez compris qu'il existe pleins d'outils pour analyser les émotions ou les réactions d'une personne.
Quand ils s'agit de faire ce travail là sur soi, alors là c'est beaucoup plus compliqué.
Et après en avoir fait l'expérience de manière intensive, avec toujours une pièce dans la poche, je peux vous dire que c'est une très bonne méthode d'auto lecture.
Vous vous mentalisez mais de manière complètement autonome.
Evidemment je vous conseille de passer d'abord par la phase de faire les "+" et les "-".
Ce que j'appelle les "+" et les "-", ce sont avantages/inconvénients, de chaque choix.
Et d'utiliser ensuite la pièce si l'analyse de départ ne suffit pas.
Mais ! Et c'est ça que j'ai découvert en l'utilisant, c'est que même pour les petites prises de décisions rapides, ça peut être très utile.
Ça permet de s'auto analyser émotionnellement, très rapidement.
Il suffit juste de se mettre en condition de se dire "je joue le jeu comme si je devais absolument suivre le résultat de la pièce."
Après j'imagine que certains d'entre vous ont d'autres méthodes pour ça.
Et je serai ravi de les découvrir dans les commentaires !
Aussi bien pour la préparation d'une prise de décision, que pour l'analyse émotionnelle face à un choix.
Si vous avez vos propres trucs, vos propres astuces, vous pouvez les partager avec nous.
Ce sera bénéfique à l'ensemble de la Team de connaitre plusieurs techniques personnelles.
J'espère que cette vidéo vous sera utile.
Pensez à laisser un petit pouce en l'air. Il n'y a pas besoin de le jouer à pile ou face celui-ci.
Et à vous abonner à la chaîne, puisque le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an du premier janvier au 31 décembre.
Donc rendez-vous demain à 11H.
Ciao !
[musique du générique de fin]
Et vous êtes encore là !
C'est génial !
Mercredi dernier lors du Meet Up, j'ai annoncé une petite exclue
dont j'ai commencé aussi à parler hier matin sur les réseaux sociaux,
et que je vais vous partager ici avec une petite annonce.
Comme vous le savez, je prends toujours le temps de vous rencontrer à la fin des spectacles.
C'est un super moment pour moi aussi c'est très agréable.
Donc je joue durant 1H30 et en général on repasse 1H30 ensemble derrière.
Le seul moyen de connaitre à l'avance toutes les dates de tournée, c'est d'aller sur mon site: www.fabienolicard.fr
Vous avez dans toutes les vidéos depuis le début de l'année, le lien dans la description.
Donc je vais passer dans tous ces endroits, mais ne vous inquiétez pas, régulièrement je rajoute d'autres dates, d'autres villes, suivant comment la tournée s’organise.
L'exclue, c'est que je vais faire une date à Paris de mon spectacle actuel "Fabien Olicard Vous Mentalise". Une date.
Il y a un ami qui s'appelle Gérald Dahan, vous savez c'est celui qui faisait la voix des minikeums quand on était tout petit.
Il ouvre un nouveau lieu à Paris et il m'a demandé si je voulais bien venir jouer mon spectacle.
Je lui ai dit: "Oui !"
Est-ce qu'on se verra ensemble à la fin ?
Je vous dit: "Oui !"
C'est le 17 décembre. Je vous mets les infos dans la description.
Mais attention au moment où je vous parle il ne reste déjà plus que 79 places.
Du moins il restait ça hier soir au moment où j'ai eu Gérald au téléphone.
Alors je ne vais pas vous faire le coup de: "Ah dépêchez-vous !", tout ça, tout ça, en mode "technique marketing".
Vous faites comme vous voulez, mais comme on m'a reproché pour le Meet Up de ne pas avoir prévenu à l'avance et qu'en 45 min le  Meet Up était complet,
ce coup ci, voilà, je vous le dis !
Il reste 79 places. Ce n'est pas un immense lieu.
C'est un bateau-péniche-théâtre.
En tout cas j'ai hâte de vous voir à Paris ou en tournée.
Passez un bon week-end.
A demain.
Ciao !